the Rich Eisen show  it's called the win loss game I love it  walk us through the schedule and we're  going to figure it out weight loss win  loss uh first Sunday of the Season at  the Tennessee Titans winter loss Paul  verzi winter loss the Giants gonna win  that game by three look at that you can  even give me a score home for the  Carolina Panthers week two  disappointing loss wow okay uh by the  way I love the adjectives disappointing  loss all right uh home for the Cowboys  Monday Night Football week three loss  home for the Chicago Bears week four win  all right so they go one and two under  stretch of three straight home games  that would not be good taking on the uh  the Packers that's a win uh in London  you of course because you're going there  home for the Ravens that's a win win at  the Jacksonville Jaguars that's a win at  the Seattle Seahawks it's a loss wow  they're foreign  yeah because that's where Jones is gonna  hit his stride